Hello, this is Sonny calling
from a very rainy Houston,
Texas radio lab is supported by dash
digital cash dash allows you to send any
amount of money using a highly
secure peer to peer network.
Skip the bank entirely and
control your money your way.
Dash is digital cash.
For more information,
visit dash.org forward slash radio labs.
Hey, it's Molly Webster from radio
lab. Before we get into the show today,
I wanted to tell you something and that's
it. Radio lab has a newsletter. We do.
It's awesome. You should sign up for it.
You'd be the first to
know about new episodes.
You'd get updates on old ones
and lots more to sign up. Go to
radiolab.org/newsletter see ya.
This is Radiolab.
I'm Jana [inaudible] and I'm Robert
Krulwich and this hour we're talking about
space, sending stuff into space,
little messages in bottles or capsules
as it were so that the extraterrestrials
of the future might one day
find if there are really
well, yes, yes, yes,
but surely there are,
I mean someday android space capsule is
bound to run into someone and they'll
know about us. Wow. Um,
just the second year,
I know that the Anne story was beautiful
and that you're in some kind of
romantic haze. How did you adjust,
get a little more cold-hearted
here about solid facts.
You might feel differently about this
whole thing. What do you mean? Well,
what do you think is the likelihood of
Ann's message of love ever being read by
an intelligent alien somewhere?
See where you're going with this?
What do you have to ask that
question? I mean it's just a gesture.
It's like a romantic phone.
No, this is an attempt.
I think to be fair to her
had a real conversation.
She wants someone to hear about this,
but the chances are so remote. When
you consider the vastness of space,
suppose for example, you wanted
to visit just a make it easy.
The very next star to us. Okay.
Actually it's too lucky
to meet a civilization.
I think it'd be so hard to come out
and flame one in the very first stop.
Let's go four stars out to
a called Zita to calm a B.
I see you hang up. I look,
I admit I looked it up.
If we increase the speed of the voyager
capsule and drains message from 35,000
miles an hour, that's how fast she
was going, right? Yeah, that's right.
Increase that speed to say
a million miles an hour.
How long do you think would it take
for you to get to Zeta to county?
300 years. Hmm. 30,000 years.
Seriously.
Wow. This Jetta, boom. Rod
is a 1200 generation trip.
Do you know where the air boom rounds
where 1200 generations ago where they were
living in a cave, beating on a
drum? That's what they were doing.
So imagine a space trip in which you
have to go forward. 1200 generations.
That's a long trip. You're such a downer.
You think that's tough. Listen to this.
There's a whole nother problem
we're going to have to deal with,
not the of distance. In this
case, there's a problem of time.
We have one of those two.
Every civilization has an arc.
You can think of it in
threes. Step one, step two
Jackson and his Chesterfield.
Bam Ray body.
Okay.
What the hell is that? Well,
a million years ago we
were practically apes.
We'd hardly begun to have
conversations. Now we have technology,
we have radio and TV and
the universe can hear us
[inaudible]
but how long will it be,
do you think before either from global
warming or for some kind of war?
We're [inaudible]
[inaudible]
the way the news has been recently days,
weeks in case I'm going to guess like
a hundred million years or 10 million
years, but that's still a
flash of time in a universe.
Now suppose instead of one civilization,
let's have two civilizations
and other one out there.
If they arrive on earth
ready to talk and we're old,
then there's no way to have the
conversation. Or on the other hand,
if they arrive on earth after
[inaudible]
nobody to talk to,
and in a 14 billion year universe with
each civilization lasting, you know,
only 10 million years,
what are the chances of two civilizations
lining up in perfect synchrony so they
can have a conversation? It's almost
mathematically impossible. Yeah, fine,
fine. But you have to keep something in
mind though. All right, well, as a rule,
people who make the argument you're
making right now, pessimists, as it were,
as a rule,
those people are usually proven wrong
at say that's always how it goes in mid
[inaudible]. Well, I'm in the
history of human navigation.
Lots of things have seemed to lonely
and too far away until someone did.
This is the guy who produced the
voyager record. His name is Tim Ferris,
I mean settling Polynesia in canoes,
navigating by the stars and the currents
alone hitting a tiny island after
crossing hundreds or even
thousands of miles of open ocean.
That's a pretty lonely,
scary thing to do and yet
thousands of Polynesians did it.
So I don't know what our
future in interstellar space
flight will be, but it's,
it is important to keep in mind that the
record of people who said that this or
that journey of exploration is
impossible or ill-advised historically,
those sorts of predictions
have not fared very well. Yes,
you just hold your horses,
right. I mean, look,
Tim is talking about the
Pacific Ocean, which is big,
but I'm talking about them.
University of mind is a much,
much bigger space in there for a
much, much, much bigger problem.
And when I want to ask questions about
space, a yes, I usually go to this guy.
Now I realize why was talking to
here. I hear you through that speaker,
but not through my
headphones. Who is this?
This is Brian Green professor
of mathematics and Physics
at Columbia University.
We are on, okay, so jet, I said to Brian,
if we've got a spacecraft
crawling through this vast,
vast empty university,
how long a trip is it for?
Just to start from wherever it is now
to the, to the end of the university.
By the way, what is, where
is the end of the universe?
That's a very natural question. You know,
in most environments you can walk for
a while, but then you hit the end.
You hit the end of the city, the end
of the state, the end of the country.
But when it comes to the universe, we
believe that there's probably no edge.
There is no end
[inaudible].
Now, how do you picture that?
The one possibility is it may be that
the universe just goes on forever.
Space may just carry on.
You just keep on going and you'll
just never run out of space.
The other possibility is it could be
that you walk off into space for a while
and you keep on walking and after a
while you realize that you've actually
circled back to your starting point.
Sort of like on the surface of
the earth. You don't find an edge.
You can't fall off the earth surface
because when you walk ultimately you'll
come back to you starting point.
That idea may apply to the fabric
of space to the entire cosmos.
Although the earth analogy is a little
insufficient cause when I'm walking in
central park,
I am on the edge of the earth
because when I look down I see earth,
but when I look up I see none earth.
I see guests around the earth,
so I'm at the edge. Well
as if I were on a balloon,
I'm on the surface of the balloon
looking out at non balloon nests.
Yeah. That's where the analogy fails.
If you're on the surface of the earth,
you can jump off, you can jump up.
Yeah. So feels like you're on an edge.
But in the universe there is no notion
of jumping off because there is nothing
beyond the space that we inhabit.
It is all there is and there
is nothing outside of it.
And now to make things even harder for
our little capsule traveling through
space, we now know that space,
that the universe and the space that it
is is expanding, constantly expanding.
So imagine our little craft all alone
in nothingness and every minute there's
more nothingness and more
nothingness and more nothing.
And as this always been happening,
we think it's been happening
since the very beginning.
So if the big bang was the origin of
the universe and this expansion has been
going on for 13.7 billion years,
so there's more space all the time. Yes.
Does that mean that it
takes a longer time to go from one
part of the universe to another?
Is that absolutely.
Absolutely.
So when you say something like,
so the universe is expanding,
what that to mean to you
is that the empty spaces in the
universe are getting bigger. Yes.
So the,
the intuitive but wrong picture would be
that you picture the universe expanding
into a preexisting space.
It preexists existing realm that the
universe is now filling like a balloon,
like a balloon filling, say the room
in which you're blowing it up. Yeah.
But that imagery is wrong
in the following way.
It's not that the universe is
expanding into a preexisting space.
It's that as the universe
expands, it creates more space.
It creates the new space
that then inhabits.
Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
Does that mean that there's no
middle of the universe? Yes.
The old idea was that there is
a central point in the universe,
and the old idea was that we were at
that central point in the universe,
but in the current way and more modern
way of thinking about the universe,
there is no center. The
Universe is actually expanding,
but it's not expanding from
a certain point in space.
All of space is stretching uniformly.
Oh mm mm, okay.
Mm.
Brian Green is professor of physics
and Mathematics at Columbia University.
This leaves us in a sort
of strange position. Yeah,
lonely position in the sense that we
have this little capsule riding somewhere
in a space which just keeps changing.
We don't know where it is or where we
are relative to other things and whatever
we know is changing all the
time. It used to be so different.
Hello, Neil degrasse Tyson,
who runs the Hayden Planetarium in New
York City because once upon a time we
knew where we were always.
We thought we knew where we were
and we were the stars. Well,
before [inaudible] Copernicus,
the idea of our place in the universe
was largely accepted to be the center.
It looked that way for sure.
You stand here on earth and look up and
the sun rises and sets on the moon rises
and sets and the stars rise and set and
the planets rise and set a Copernicus
came around.
He put the sun in the middle
of the known universe,
allowing the planets to
then go around the sun,
relegating earth to the status of a planet
being one of these objects that goes
around the sun. Now, that was a
very dangerous idea at the time.
Apparently, yes,
because that idea conflicted with all
prevailing interpretation of scripture.
It had deep societal ramifications,
and Copernicus knew this. He
knew it so well that he said,
I'm going to make sure I'm dead
before this hits the best seller list.
So he didn't want to publish
during his own lifetime.
This book was basically published on his
deathbed as competitive as 16 hundreds
oh 1515 oh yeah. 15 three
I think was the pub date.
So now what happens? So,
so now we're no longer humankind is no
longer at the center of things. Now what?
Well, we're no longer at the
center of the then known universe,
then known universe was the objects
of the solar system, the planets.
But you look up at the night sky beyond
the planets. What do you see? Stars?
They're stars in every direction. In fact,
if you count how many stars are to
your left, how many are to your right,
how many are above and below? It's about
the same in every direction. You look,
hey, maybe even if earth is not
the center of the solar system,
the solar system is in the center
of the rest of the universe.
Yeah, there. Yeah.
That's the ticket. Okay.
Now we can dig out of this
hole the Kapernick put us in.
Let's go ahead and do that. So
that group is king. No. Yeah.
Our little family of planets were in the
center and so that prevail for awhile
because it's a comforting
concept, not only for the public,
but for the scientist as well.
It wasn't until the 1920s where Harlow
Shapley then head of Harvard College
Observatory noticed globular clusters.
Those were more in one direction
of the sky than the other
and he deduced that these things ought
to know where the center of the gravity
is rather than these measly handful of
stars that are sitting in front of us
around on the sky.
I mean these big fat concentration
of fat hundred thousand star Beehive
concentrations of stars, star clusters,
they ought to know where
the center of the galaxy is,
even if these single stars don't.
And so he deduced that the center of
the galaxy was off in the direction of
Sagittarius on the sky. Okay,
so now people are fighting that.
People fighting that,
but then all hell breaks
loose because 1920s come in.
Edwin Hubble grabs the business end of
the biggest telescope of the day and
determines that these fuzzy things among
the stars are not the same distance as
the stars themselves. They're vastly
farther away. In fact, you know,
they kind of look like what
this collection of stars
might look like from afar.
In fact, maybe they are other milky ways.
Maybe they are other galaxies.
Maybe we're not the
whole story. Oh boy, man.
While this guy keeps getting bigger and
bigger and deeper and deeper and bigger
and deeper and bigger and deeper. Yeah.
Oh, this was terrible for the ego.
I can tell you I'm disappointed
myself. Oh Man. And so now, okay,
maybe we're in the center of the
universe because we look this way.
We see about the same number of galaxies
this way is that way, is that way,
is that way it kind of looks like we're
at the center and they're all receding
from us. So Hey, wait the
center then you know, but,
but now we're smarter than this. Now we're
saying we're not gonna fall for that.
[inaudible] okay, we fallen for
that one nine times already.
We're not gonna fall for this again.
Somebody is sitting there in the corner
thinking every time we'll make ourselves
the star of the show,
we're wrong, we're wrong.
So we're not going to
make that mistake again.
And so you then apply Einstein's general
theory of relativity and it says if you
live in an expanding universe in
this fabric of space and time,
no matter where you are, it will
look like you're at the center.
Which means what? There is no center.
Yes. Every center is an illusion. Yes.
And so that's how we could look like we're
at the center of the actual universe,
even though we're not,
because everybody sees the same
signature of the expansion.
Now there's an even stronger
argument for then the numerics.
Let's look at the ingredients
of the human body.
You learn from biology class where
mostly water, right, but what is water?
Mostly? Hydrogen and hydrogen.
Actually, let's look in the cosmos.
The number one ingredient in the cosmos
was hydrogen. Next in the universe,
oxygen next on earth and in life.
Oxygen next in the universe.
Carbon next in life. Carbon next
in the universe of nitrogen.
Next online nitrogen, one for
one. You go down the list.
We are not simply in this
universe. The universe is in us,
so we're not the center of the
universe. We're on this side.
Then our gang is not the
center of everything,
but it's just out on a wing and then a
galaxy that we're a part of is one of
many and the fact that we are alive is
maybe not unique. I got some, hello,
can we go? We can go lower. You're
ready? Do you want to go lower? Okay.
We may not even be the
principle stuff of the universe.
That's how insignificant we are. Okay?
We have learned the universe has this
stuff that has gravity but doesn't
otherwise interact with matter
as we know it. It doesn't shine.
It doesn't reflect. It doesn't block.
It's dark. It's called dark matter,
so how
travel the universe is the stuff that
we can either see or that is blocked,
but we can kind of detect
4%
[inaudible] glow. I took
you guys, how low can we go?
96% of the university's
missing. 96% universe is not us.
It's something else.
Is it your working bias that if I came
to you with a new discovery in which we
were less important or discovery,
which proposed that we were more
important that you would guess that my
scientific discovery that said we are
less important is more likely to be right.
No doubt about it. That's correct.
Now you call that a bias, but I don't.
I call that track record.
Okay. Track record we
have among our exhibits.
Here are a timeline of the universe that
begins with the big bang and you walk
the equivalent length of 100 yards
and time goes by with every step.
You take million years depending
on how long your legs are.
[inaudible] 70 million years
per step, yes, per step.
And you do that for a hundred yards and
you get near the bottom. Uh, it's a,
it's a gently sloping ramp.
You get to the bottom of the ramp and
then you're reminded that 65 million years
ago,
the dinosaurs were roaming the
earth ready to become extinct.
And then you take one more step on this
ramp and you reach modern day. Well,
at the end of that ramp, we have
mounted a single strand of human hair.
The left side of that hair,
cavemen would join cave paintings.
The right side of that hair is
this conversation right now.
So we are a Spec on a Spec,
on a Spec, on a Spec,
and the Spec that you just heard talking
was over six feet tall. By the way,
is Neil degrasse Tyson,
astrophysicist and director of the
Hayden Planetarium in New York City?
Is He that? That right there though,
is why I think a lot of people don't
like science because any time that anyone
normal wants to say that we are important.
There's some scientists in
the corner who's yelling, man,
that's what you spec clients.
His preference, but I don't
know. I think artists,
Shakespeare for example, who says
what a piece of work is, man,
how noble and reason and all.
It seems like it's arched job
to say that we are special,
significant, glorious,
and it's science's job to say,
no, we're not. Right. Well,
well maybe art is where we should go
next. Stay with us. I'm Jack [inaudible].
I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
will continue in a moment.